This video is brought to you by Portuguese pod one Oh one.
If you've always wanted to learn Portuguese,
there's no better time than right now.
And you can make it happen with Portuguese pod one Oh one,
click the link in the description to get started with a free account. Hello,
everyone. Welcome to the Lang focus channel. And my name is Paul. Today.
We're going to focus on the two major varieties of Portuguese,
real Portuguese and fake Portuguese.
Now speakers of both varieties love me because they're sure I just called the
other one fake
while still being varieties of the same language.
The Portuguese spoken in Brazil and the Portuguese spoken in Portugal are
significantly different in terms of pronunciation,
vocabulary and grammar Brazilians often say it's difficult to understand
Portuguese people and Portuguese people often say that Brazilians speak
incorrect or broken Portuguese.
[Inaudible] what is United to shell? North call returned.
She [inaudible] centrally drop, uh,
[inaudible] DVD then traditional cash.
Brasilia capital. Whereas you
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] but as
[inaudible].
The samples you just heard were up the Brazilians say accent of Brasilia and the
accent of Lisbon Portugal.
There's a lot of variation within each country as well,
but these two accents are more or less representative of the main differences
between European Portuguese and Brazilian Portuguese.
Even if you don't know any Portuguese,
you may have noticed that something was different about the way the two
varieties were pronounced. European Portuguese is stress timed.
At least to a large extent,
I talked about European Portuguese being a stress timed language in my video
explaining why Portuguese and Russian sound similar in the stress time language.
The length of time between stressed syllables remains relatively consistent in
order to fit into that relatively fixed interval between stress syllables,
unstressed syllables tend to become shorter.
That results in lots of vowel reduction. In contrast,
Brazilian Portuguese is syllable timed in syllable timed languages.
Each syllable lasts for a more or less equal duration of time.
Lots of vowels that are reduced or dropped in European Portuguese are generally
pronounced more fully and clearly in Brazilian Portuguese. For example,
this word meaning excellent in European Portuguese.
Splints splint, and then Brazilian Portuguese.
Is it Lynch? Is it Lynch.
Slipped? Another major.
Difference in pronunciation involves the L sound in either language at the end
of a word or a syllable in European Portuguese it's Oh, or, Oh,
like a dark L sound in Brazilian Portuguese. It's like a whoosh,
like a w sound after a vowel. For example, the word for a couple.
Because the.
Sound represented by the letter S is also different in some contexts in European
Portuguese it's HSA before a voiceless consonant,
even if it's in the following word and before a pause, in other words,
at the end of a word,
if there's nothing right after it in most Brazilian accents it's before a
voiceless consonant and before a pause, for example,
the phrase meaning pretty good.
Okay.
Note that in some Brazilian accent, such as the Carioca accent,
the European sound is used before a voiced consonant in European
Portuguese. It's in Brazilian Portuguese it's in most accents,
for example, the word meanings.
Miserable, miserable.
Note that between vowels it's Zed in both European and Brazilian accent,
we saw this before in the word.
Cause the.
Sound also differs between the two countries,
depending on the context it appears in.
There's plenty of variation of the R sound within each country too.
But I'll try to give the general tendencies when at the beginning of a word or
doubled in European Portuguese,
it's similar to a French or German R while in Brazilian Portuguese
it's huh? Huh? Or hot, for example.
At the end.
Of a syllable,
it's the same as above in Brazilian Portuguese in European Portuguese,
it's normally an alveolar tap, for example.
Nope.
Between vowels or after a continent, but before a vowel,
it's an alveolar tap in both varieties.
Another character.
Difference is the pronunciation of D followed by I in Portugal.
It's pronounced D or the usually when,
between vowels in Brazilian Portuguese it's G for example, the word for D.
Gee, there's a parallel.
Difference in the pronunciation of tea followed by I in Portugal.
It's T though the vowel may be reduced and unstressed syllables in Brazil.
It's cheap. For example, the word for ant.
Yeah. She, uh.
Sounds ju and cha result from palatalization.
Palatalization also occurs in D E N T E when they're unstressed with no
accent Mark. And when they're followed by a,
in the next syllable that's because in those cases,
the letter E actually sounds like the letter. I, for example.
Nope.
And in some areas such as the Northeast of Brazil, this doesn't occur.
The Portuguese varieties of Portugal and Brazil share the vast majority of their
vocabulary,
but just like British people and North American people use some different
vocabulary. So do people from Portugal and Brazil,
the words for Trane in European, Portuguese it's kumbaya,
but in Brazilian Portuguese it's, which comes from the English word trend.
The words for bus,
The words for catching a lift or hitching a ride.
Player got on it.
The words for bathroom in Portugal it's caused by which means how self
bathing, but in Brazil, it's interestingly in Portugal,
this word actually means lifeguard. The words for toilet.
[Inaudible] the words for fruit juice Sumo.
So breakfast almost this means little lunch
[inaudible] this means.
Morning coffee, refrigerator.
Jayla data in Brazilian Portuguese [inaudible] is used with.
The meaning of meat processing plant.
I imagine it was originally used to refer to a cold storage facility for meat.
Let's look at a sentence for a second.
There is milk and juice in the fridge in Portugal,
a lady swimmer and in Brazil.
[Inaudible] data in both.
Varieties, word for word it's. There is milk and juice in the fridge.
Aside from the different vocabulary,
notice the different pronunciation of the word, familiar.
Talk late Legion again.
And we hear the difference in how tee is pronounced.
When unstressed the words for cell phones.
Kelly, Morville Sila.
The words for screen, meaning the screen of a TV or computer in Portugal.
It's [inaudible], which comes from French eCom in Brazil. It's Dayla
this word also occurs in European Portuguese, but it's
used for other types of screens or canvases
, not screens on electronic devices. The words for three piece suit are different. The meaning of
three-piece
suit is unique to Brazilian Portuguese, but this word exists in Portuguese, in general, with the meaning of trio or set of three, there
are
quite a few words like that that have different meanings in either country. Sometimes their primary meaning is different, and sometimes there's an additional meaning that doesn't exist in the other country.
Kimmy's Zola in Portugal. This means t-shirt or sweater.
Gummies Zola in Brazil. It.
Means nightgown or night dress.
Some of these words can be a little dangerous in Portugal.
This means boy in Brazil,
one meaning is to be really angry. And another meaning is well,
a male prostitute. Similarly in Portugal,
this means a young.
Lady, how by the IGA in Brazil.
This means a female prostitute for the meaning of a young lady in Brazilian
Portuguese. The word meaning can be used
in Portugal. This means university tuition fee, but it will be in Brazil.
It means a bribe.
There are a few differences in grammar between European and Brazilian
Portuguese, second person, singular pronouns,
European Portuguese uses to as the familiar second person, singular pronoun,
and Vasa as the informal,
but unfamiliar form used with people of similar age or status who you don't know
very well. Brazilian Portuguese uses, we'll say as the informal second person,
singular pronoun, both familiar and unfamiliar.
This is true in the standard form of Brazilian Portuguese.
And in many dialects though, some dialects retain two. For example,
you sing well in European Portuguese, and in Brazilian.
[Inaudible].
Kind of pronoun mixing often takes place in Brazilian Portuguese with VOSA being
used as the subject pronoun together with the equivalent of two as the object
pronoun or the possessive. For example, for the phrase you and your son,
you might.
Here, this will say, they'll feel rather than this. We'll say, however, it,
both of them are used.
The dialects of Brazilian Portuguese that do use to the conjugation for VSA,
which is really a third person, singular conjugation is often used.
So again, this is a kind of mixed form that only occurs in Brazil,
placement of object, pronouns, object pronouns in Portuguese,
or normally critics that attach themselves close to the verb.
There are sometimes positioned differently in the two varieties in European
Portuguese. They're often in-clinic placed after the verb. And in some cases,
our Mayo clinic in the middle of the verb in Brazilian Portuguese,
they are generally pro clinic meaning before the verb,
except in compound tenses in which they come after the auxiliary verb.
And before the main verb, for example, a sentence,
meaning he saw me in European Portuguese and in Brazilian Portuguese.
In European.
Portuguese Mayo clinic object pronouns are used in the future indicative tents
and the conditional in Brazilian Portuguese.
This is considered archaic and it's rarely used for example, the sentence,
meaning I would help you in European Portuguese
and in Brazilian Portuguese.
Notice how the.
Object pronoun in European Portuguese is placed right between the verb STEM and
its inflectional ending though. This is a formal and literary form,
continuous forms,
continuous verb forms like the present continuous are formed differently in
Brazilian Portuguese it's is the plus the Gerand, but in European Portuguese,
it's formed with [inaudible] plus plus the infinitive.
So take the phrase for I'm speaking in Brazilian Portuguese.
And in European Portuguese it's [inaudible].
From what I understand, this is one difference that really, really,
really annoys Portuguese speakers from Portugal who insists that it's terribly
incorrect. Portuguese is.
[Inaudible].
Take the sentence. We are learning Portuguese, but it's difficult. Thumbs up.
First.
You can see the difference in the present continuous tense that we talked about
a moment ago, thumbs up, thumbs up in the end. Aside from that,
these sentences are pretty much the same except for their pronunciation
is the most in this word,
you can hear the difference in the S sounds sure in European,
Portuguese and SU in Brazilian Portuguese,
you can also hear the vowel reduction in the European word with the first vowel,
basically dropped and notice this word [inaudible]
in this word,
you can hear the Brazilian G sound at the beginning while in the European word
it's D you can also hear the Brazilian L as it's pronounced at the end of a word
or a syllable like w European,
Portuguese and Brazilian Portuguese are clearly varieties of the same language.
And in terms of grammar and vocabulary, they are the same for the most part.
But as you saw earlier,
there are some differences that really stand out when you encounter them,
especially words that have different meanings in either variety,
but the biggest difference lies in the phonology of the two varieties or their
systems of pronunciation.
That's probably the thing that often makes it difficult for speakers of one
variety to understand the other,
but that difference can be overcome by learning about what's different between
the two varieties and gaining exposure to the other one.
But that's just how it seems to me. What do I know?
Let's ask native speakers of Portuguese,
the question of the day for native speakers of European and Brazilian
Portuguese,
how easy is it for you to understand and communicate with speakers of the other
variety and other people?
What do you think of the differences between the two varieties?
How major do they seem to you?
I know some of the people watching this video already know Portuguese and others
wish they knew Portuguese better,
but isn't it time to stop wishing and actually make it happen.
And you can make it happen with Portuguese pod, one Oh one Portuguese pod,
one Oh one is produced by innovative language who have millions of members all
over the world. They offer concise,
easy to understand lessons that you can complete at home in the car,
or while waiting for your friend who always shows up late,
improve your listening and pronunciation with their main audio lessons,
improve your vocabulary with their review tools and word lists,
and learn all the basics of how the language works with their simplified grammar
explanations.
There's no better time than right now to start learning Portuguese or whichever
language you've always wanted to learn.
Click the link in the description or visit Lang
focused.com/portuguese pod to get started with a free account.
I want to give a big shout out to all the Lang focused Patrion members,
especially the top tier patrons whose names appear on the screen.
Other benefits,
including seeing videos before everyone else access to exclusive bonus videos
and a private Lang focus online community, check out
patrion.com/lang focus to see how you can become a patron and to everyone.
Thank you for watching and have a nice day.